if you've ever read the book of genesis
which is the part of the old testament
that details god creating the world and
humanity during a particularly busy week
then you might just be already familiar
with scp-001
or at least one of the anomalies that's
been proposed for the title of scp-001
because of course
scp-001 doesn't refer to a single
creature object or entity but rather a
collection of various anomalies
contained by the scp foundation
anomalies sharing the name scp-001
include the infamous scarlet king a
powerful eldritch being intent on ending
all of creation that is thought by
foundation researchers to be one of the
most dangerous beings in this and any
other universe but the scarlet king
isn't the only incredibly powerful being
categorized as
scp-001 in fact there are plenty of
other anomalies with similar levels of
destructive power and one such being is
a creature codenamed the gate guardian
standing at well over a thousand feet
tall the gate guardian is impossible to
be fully contained by any means that the
foundation possesses the anomaly itself
despite its colossal size is humanoid in
its shape sporting wings that protrude
from its back while it usually has four
of these
scp-001 has historically been seen to
have any number of wings between 2 and
108 sprouting from various places over
its body including its shoulders ankles
wrists and even its temples this
gigantic guardian also carries its own
weapon referred to as scp-001-2
this weapon resembles an enormous knife
or sword capable of emitting plumes of
flame according to tests conducted by
the foundation the temperature of the
flames produced by scp-001 rivaled that
of our very own sun for reference the
sun has a core temperature of over 27
million degrees fahrenheit and
5778 kelvin at its surface or almost 10
000 degrees fahrenheit you would expect
a flaming sword that burns hotter than
the sun to cause a considerable amount
of damage even if it wasn't in use but
the flames emitted by the weapon leave
no lasting damage on the surrounding
environment it is capable though of
annihilating anything that strays too
close to scp-001
burning them so intensely that their
atoms literally separate breaking
potential attackers apart on a molecular
level much as its code name suggests the
gate guardian stands solemnly at the
threshold of some form of dimensional
gateway which is equally tall as scp-001
itself behind the guardian is a lush
grove abundant with fruit trees of
astronomical size as well as other
beings that share a similar appearance
to scp-001
this grove is thought to be the garden
of eden the paradise that god created
and that was inhabited by adam and eve
the first two humans in existence
according to the book of genesis as the
tale goes the pair were created by god
himself and permitted to live in the
garden of eden as long as they followed
a single rule adam and eve were
instructed not to eat any of the fruit
that grew from certain trees that god
had specified within view just behind
the gate guardian are two immense trees
one bearing apples and the other bearing
different fruit of an unknown type the
one that looks like an apple tree is
believed even by some in the foundation
to be the biblical tree of knowledge
that eve was convinced to pick a fateful
apple from after an encounter with a
snake the other the one with
unidentifiable fruit is thought to be
the tree of life however this is all
speculation since it is currently
impossible to venture through this
gateway and verify if the realm beyond
is truly the bible's own garden of eden
this is largely because anything that
breaches a kilometer wide radius of
scp-001 is instantly vaporized the gate
guardian attacks with imperceptible
speed using its flaming sword to smite
any person that gets too close the
guardian actually moves so fast that it
can hardly be seen with the naked eye it
appears to always remain in its solemn
dutiful stance with its weapon drawn and
head bowed only shifting for a fraction
of a nanosecond to attack ranged attacks
against the guardian are just as
ineffective with all projectiles fired
at scp-001 reduced to atoms before they
can do any harm even if said projectile
happens to be a nuclear weapon the gate
guardian will be able to sub-atomically
vaporize both the projectile itself as
well as the person who sent it
regardless of how far away they are all
while not appearing to lift a finger
during an experiment involving scp-001
on december 26 2004 an scp foundation
nuclear submarine called nautilus
launched a series of multi-warhead
intercontinental ballistic missiles at
the gate guardian the retaliation from
the guardian resulted not only in the
depths of approximately 35 000 innocent
civilians but the blast is also believed
by some to have inadvertently caused the
2004 boxing day tsunami the severity of
this incident came dangerously close to
revealing the foundation's existence to
the world resulting in them rapidly
deploying any means necessary to erase
any trace of the 35 000 victims families
friends and other related individuals in
order to avoid questioning the scp
foundation administered amnestics on an
almost worldwide scale and the o5
council banned any further tests on
scp-001 that involved nuclear weapons in
what was hoped by the foundation to be a
test with lower stakes they sent an
expendable d-class personnel towards
scp-001
the d-class approached the area where
the gate guardian is located and as soon
as they saw it they could hear a very
clear command in their mind leave
the d-class personnel reacted exactly
the same way you or i would they
promptly turned and started to walk away
they didn't need a thousand foot tall
entity with a flaming sword to tell them
twice the researchers running the
experiment were not swayed by the
request and ordered the d-class to
continue moving towards scp-008
when the d-class continued to ignore
their commands they were terminated as
is standard policy when dealing with an
insubordinate member of d-class
scp-001 appeared not to like this for
some reason though and the researchers
site as well as the researchers
themselves were immediately obliterated
by an unknown force though it's a pretty
safe guess that a certain flaming weapon
was responsible this candidate for
scp-001 may be one of if not the most
powerful being that the scp foundation
has ever encountered and according to
its entry in the scp-001
file the guardian is even responsible
for the creation of the foundation
itself if the file is to be believed the
administrator of the scp foundation one
day heard a word echoing through his
head prepare
this one word instruction led him to
starting the scp foundation containing
countless dangerous anomalies and
entities in preparation for an uncertain
future in all that time since the very
beginning of the foundation the gate
guardian has remained standing at its
post while it is not aggressive nor
openly hostile towards humanity the gate
guardian doesn't seem to care much for
us either at least as individuals it
rarely interacts with human beings when
left unprovoked and venturing too close
to the guardian however is not an
automatic death sentence the guardian
first communicates with any living being
approaching it via telepathic message
instructing them to either leave or
forget if whomever has stepped too close
to scp-001 complies with the
instructions they'll be able to freely
leave the area while simultaneously
forgetting every detail of the gate
guardian's existence ignore these
warnings though and scp-001 has no
qualms about completely eliminating you
from reality given its enormous
destructive potential it is no wonder
that the foundation has tried to use the
gate guardian to eliminate other
dangerous scps each with varying results
the foundation at one time even
attempted to use the gate guardian to
destroy the infamously indestructible
scp-682 better known by the appropriate
name of the hard to destroy reptile due
to the malicious contempt scp-682 holds
for human beings and all other forms of
life it is perhaps one of the most
dangerous anomalies the scp foundation
has in containment
scp-682 is also one of the few creatures
the foundation actively wants to
terminate a task made that much harder
given that 682 can regenerate its entire
form from as little as a single cell the
gate guardian had already shown time and
time again that it was capable of
massive destruction and researchers
working for the foundation hoped to
harness that power to rid the world of
scp-682
for good 682 was placed on an unmanned
vehicle and carried to within one
kilometer of the gate guardian the
guardian attacked the vehicle seriously
wounding but not killing 682 it seemed
even the mighty scp-001
couldn't kill the hard to destroy
reptile while the researchers were
disappointed with this result it is
worth noting that 682 made a very
interesting comment to the guardian 682
mentioned that the gate guardian is not
uriel but a pretender uriel is the arch
angel that some religious texts describe
as the guardian standing at the gate of
eden with a fiery sword so does this
mean that 682 knows that the gate
guardian is not actually an angel or
that the location it is guarding isn't
the garden of eden at all any truth or
meaning behind these comments has as of
yet been undetermined by the scp
foundation a later experiment involved
both scp-001
and
scp-073 the anomaly otherwise known as
kane kane is a male humanoid of possible
arabic descent whose arms legs spine and
shoulders are replaced in an almost
cyborg-like fashion with beryllium
bronze much like the gate guardian
scp-073 may also be the same as the one
mentioned in the bible's book of genesis
who according to the biblical story
murdered his own brother abel out of
spite as punishment for his actions kane
was cursed to eternally suffer for his
wrong doing in the case of
scp-073 any damage inflicted on him is
deflected back to the attacker but kane
is made to feel the pain of the attack
any plants or plant-based matter withers
and rots in his presence and he is
cursed with a perfect memory keeping him
forever haunted by his murder of abel
when kane was brought before the gate
guardian an unknown incident occurred
the foundation's records are heavily
expunged but we do know that somehow
kane's usual ability to deflect incoming
damage back at his attacker had no
effect on scp-008
the encounter left scp-073 unconscious
and even permanently blinded nearby
research personnel it was as a direct
result of this incident that the o5
council demanded that no further
experiments of any kind were to be
conducted on scp-001
with the administrator even filing an
executive order that no scps be exposed
to the guardian and that
scp-001 was to never be used for the
attempted termination of other scps of
course perhaps it wasn't just the
mistakes of the past that made the
council decide that scp-001 was best
left alone at some point an erratic
transmission was received from site zero
by foundation personnel detailing an xk
class end of the world scenario in the
transmission the sender believed to be
another member of the scp foundation
described an event during which the gate
guardian finally left its post stepping
away from the entrance to the garden of
eden
scp-001 has left its location the sender
wrote the gate is open they are riding
forth oh god it's so beautiful the
transmission then goes on to repeat
various phrases including the lord shall
reign forever and hear o israel the lord
our god the lord is one what can be
inferred from the rambling transmission
is that the event being described is the
end of the world some believe that once
god deems it time his angelic armies
will lay ways to the earth in order to
remake it as a paradise when this occurs
as cp001 the gate guardian will open the
gate he stands in front of allowing the
other beings like it to emerge into our
world ready to cleanse it perhaps most
interesting is the source of the message
the transmission was received from
within the foundation from site zero
however when questioned by personnel
05-14 told them that no such message had
been sent or even existed while some
disregarded the transmission telling of
the end of the world as a hoax it was
then that a timestamp was discovered
this warning had not been sent from site
zero at least not yet and was dated
several years in the future despite this
ominous warning of things to come the
gate guardian remains inactive standing
at the threshold to eden waiting now
check out scp-001
which is the real
scp-001 and
scp-001 the children arboro cycle for
more facts about the mysterious scp-001
[Music]